hi I'm Annie whoo and I'm a mathematics
teacher one of the happy accidents that
I've been able to stumble into is that
my classroom being open to the world
first it was a bit of a surprise that
any students outside of my own classroom
watch because I thought how would they
even find out that these videos exist
but then to know add a whole non level
that they were are the teachers my
colleagues also watching in I have to
confess I probably never really thought
about that as a concern because I never
thought that it would happen but for me
I've just been delighted at how much you
know yeah there are people would say
yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't teach it that
way I'd teach it a different way I think
another ways clearer and I get to have
the you know I think it's really
important to have the humility to be
able to say I get to learn from you if
you've got a better way of doing this
please show me like I'm I'm not here to
say my practice is the best way like do
it the way that you see on this video
it's just one way and it's one of the
reasons why I encourage so many other
people as much as possible put a camera
in your own through what have you got to
lose
what have you got to gain and give to
others is a much more important question
I think to ask
[Music]